you
founded the payment system braintree in
2007
that acquired venmo in 2012
and then in that same year was acquired
by paypal
which is now ebay
can you tell me the story of the vision
and the challenge of building an online
payment system and just building a large
successful business in general
i discovered payments by accident as
i was when i was 21 i
i just returned from ecuador uh living
the money extreme poverty for two years
and i came back to the us and i was
shocked by the opulence and yeah of the
united states and i just thought this is
i couldn't believe it and i decided i
wanted to try to spend my life
helping others like that was the that
was a life objective that i thought was
worthwhile to pursue versus making money
and
whatever the case may be for its own
right and so i decided in that moment
that i was going to
try to make enough money by the age of
30
to never have to work again and then
with some abundance of money
i could then choose to do things that
might
be beneficial to others but may not meet
the criteria of being
you know a standalone business and so in
that process i started
a few companies had some small successes
had some
failures in one of the endeavors i was
up to my eyeballs in debt
things were not going well and i needed
a part-time job to
pay my bills and so i
one day i saw in the paper in utah where
i was living
the 50 richest people in utah and i
emailed each one of their assistants and
said you know i
i'm young i'm resourceful i'll do
anything i just wanna
i'm entrepreneurial i try to get a job
that would be flexible and
no one responded and then i interviewed
at a few dozen places nobody would even
give me the time of day
uh like it wouldn't want to take me
seriously and so finally
i it was on monster.com that i saw this
job posting for
credit card sales door-to-door
commission i did not know the story this
is great
i love the head drop that's exactly
right so it was
the low points to which would go in like
so i
i responded and you know the person made
an attempt at
suggesting that they had some kind of
standards that they would
consider in hiring but it's kind of like
if you could fog a mirror
like you come and do this because it's
100 commission and so i started walking
up and down the street in my community
selling credit card processing and so
what you learn immediately in doing that
is if you you walk into a business first
of all
the business owner is typically there
and you walk in the door and they can
tell by how you're addressed or how you
walk whatever their pattern recognition
is
and they just hate you immediately it's
like stop wasting my time i really am
trying to get stuff done i don't want to
do a sales pitch
and so you have to overcome the initial
get out
and then once you engage when you say
the word credit card
processing the person's like i already
hate you because i have been taken
advantage of
dozens of times because you all are
yeah weasels and so i had to figure out
an algorithm to get past all those
different conditions because i'm still
working on my other
startup for the majority of my time i
was doing this part-time
and so i figured out that the industry
really was
built on people
on deceit uh basically people promising
things that that were not
reality and so i'd walk into a business
and say look i would give you a hundred
dolla i'd put a 100
bill and say i'll give you a hundred
dollars for three minutes of your time
if you don't say yes to what i'm saying
i'll give you a hundred dollars
and then you usually crack a smile and
say okay like what do you got for me son
and so i'd sit down i just opened my
book and i'd say here's the credit card
industry here's how it works here are
the players here's what they do here's
how they deceive you
here's what i am i'm no different than
anyone else it's like you're going to
process your credit card you're gonna
get the money in the account you're just
gonna get a clean statement you're gonna
have someone who
answers the call when someone asks and
you know just like the basic like you're
okay
and people started saying yes and then
of course i went to the next business
and be like you know
joe and susie and whoever said yes too
and so i built the social proof
structure
and i became the number one salesperson
out of 400 people nationwide doing this
and i worked you know half time still
doing another startup
and that's a brilliant strategy by the
way it's very well like
very well strategized and executed
i did it for nine months and at the time
my
customer base was making was generating
around
i think it was sick if i remember
correctly sixty two thousand five
hundred four dollars a month
where the overall revenues i thought wow
that's amazing if i
built that as my own company i would
just make sixty two thousand dollars a
month of income
passively with these merchants
processing credit cards
so i thought hmm and so that's when i
thought i'm going to create a company
and so then i started braintree
and the idea was the online world was
broken
because paypal had uh
had been acquired by ebay around i think
201999 or 2000
and ebay had not innovated much with
paypal so it basically sat
still for seven years as the software
world moved along
and then authorized.net was also a
company that was relatively stagnant so
you basically had
software engineers who wanted modern
payment tools but there were none
available for them and so they just
dealt with software they didn't like and
so
with braintree i thought the entry point
is to build software that engineers will
love
and if we can find the entry point via
software make it easy and beautiful
and just a magical experience and then
provide customer service on top of that
that was easy that would be great
what i was really going after for though
is it was paypal
they were the only company in payments
making money
because they because they have the
relationship with ebay early on
people created a paypal account they'd
fund their account with their checking
account versus their credit cards
and then when they'd use paypal to pay a
merchant paypal had a cost of payment of
zero
versus if you have coming from a credit
card you have to pay the bank the fees
so paypal's margins were
three percent on a transaction
versus a typical payments company which
may be a nickel or a penny or a dime or
something like that
and so i knew a new paypal really was
the model to replicate but a bunch of
companies had tried to do that they
tried to come in and build a two-sided
marketplace so get consumers to
fund the checking account and merchants
to accept it but they'd all failed
because
building a two-sided marketplace is very
hard at the same time
so my plan was i'm going to build a
company and
get the best merchants in the whole
world to use our service
then in year five i'm going to have i'm
going to acquire a consumer payments
company and i'm going to bring the two
together
wow and so focus on the merchant side
exactly and then get the payments
company that does the the customer the
whatever the the other side yeah this is
the plan i presented
uh when i was at university of chicago
and
weirdly it happened exactly like that so
for four years in
our customer base included uber airbnb
github
37 signals not base camp we had a
fantastic collection of companies
that represented the fastest growing
some of the fastest growing tech
companies in the world and then
we met up with venmo and they had done a
remarkable job in building products
then something very counter-intuitive
which is make public your private
financial transactions which people
previously thought were
something that should be hidden from
others and we acquired venmo
and at that point we now had we
replicated the model because now people
could fund their venmo account with
their checking account keep money in the
account
and then you could just plug them in as
a form of payment and so
i think paypal saw that that we were
getting the best merchants in the world
we had people using venmo they were both
the up and coming millennials at the
time who had so much influence online
and so they came in and offered us uh an
attractive number
and my my goal was not to
build the biggest payments company in
the world it wasn't
to try to climb the forbes billionaire
list it was
the objective was i want to earn enough
money
so that i can basically dedicate my
attention to doing something that could
potentially be useful
on a society-wide scale and
more importantly that could be
considered to be valuable
from the vantage point of 2050
2100 and 2500 so
thinking about it on a a few hundred
year time scale
and there was a certain amount of money
i needed to do that so i didn't
require the permission of anybody to do
that and so that what paypal offered was
sufficient for me to get that amount of
money to basically have a go
and that's when i set off to
survey everything i could identify in
existence to say
of anything in the entire world i could
do what one thing could i do
that would actually have the highest
value
potential for the species and so it took
me a little while to arrive at brain
interfaces but
you know payments in themselves
are revolutionary technologies that can
change
the world like let's not
let's not uh sort of um let's not forget
that too easily i mean obviously you
know this but
there's uh quite a few lovely folks
who are now fascinated with the space of
cryptocurrency
and uh where payments are very much
connected to this but in general just
money
and many of the folks i've spoken with
they also kind of connect that to
not just purely financial discussions
but philosophical and political
discussions
and uh they see bitcoin as a way
almost as activism almost as a way to
resist
the uh the corruption of centralized the
centers of power
and sort of basically in the 21st
century decentralizing control
whether that's bitcoin or other
cryptocurrencies they see
that's one possible way to give power to
those
that live in regimes that are corrupt or
are not respectful of human rights and
all those kinds of things
what's your sense just all your
expertise with
with payments and seeing how that
changed the world what's your sense
about
the lay of the land for the future of
bitcoin or other cryptocurrencies
in the positive impact they may have in
the world
and to be clear my communication wasn't
suggest
wasn't meant to minimize payments or to
denigrate it in any way
it was a an attempted communication that
when i was surveying the world it was an
algorithm of
what could i individually yes
do so there's there are things that
exist
that have a lot of potential that can be
done and then there's
a filtering of how many people are
qualified to do this given thing
and then there's a further
characterization that can be done of
okay given the number of qualified
people
somebody be uh a unique out performer of
that group to make something truly
impossible to be something done that
otherwise couldn't get done so there's
there's a process of assessing where can
you add unique value in the world
and some of that has to do with you're
being very uh
very formal and calculative here but
some of that is just like
what do you sense like part of that
equation
is how much passion you sense within
yourself to be able to drive that
through
to discover the impossibilities and make
them possible that's right and so we we
were
a braintree i think we were the first
company to integrate coinbase
into our i think we were the first
payments company to formally
incorporate uh crypto if i'm not
mistaken
for people not familiar coinbase is a
place where you can trade
cryptocurrencies
yeah which was one of the only places
you could so we were early
uh in in doing that and of course this
was in the year
2013 so an attorney to go in in
cryptocurrency land
i concur with the the statement you made
of the potential of
the principles underlying
cryptocurrencies
and that many of the things that they're
building
in the name of money and of
of moving value is equally applicable to
the brain
and equally applicable to how the brain
interacts with the rest of the world
and how we would imagine doing goal
alignment
with people so it's to me it's a
continuous spectrum
of possibility and we're talk your
question is isolated on the money
and i think it just is basically a
scaffolding layer for all of society so
you don't see the
this money is particularly distinct from
i don't it's
i think we we at colonel we will benefit
greatly from the progress being made in
cryptocurrency
because it will be a similar technology
stack we'll want to use for
many things we want to accomplish and so
i'm bullish on what's going on
and i think it could greatly enhance uh
brain interfaces and the value of
the brain-faced ecosystem i mean is
there something you could say about
first of all bullish on cryptocurrency
versus fiat money
so do you have a sense that in 21st
century cryptocurrency will
be embraced by governments and change
the
the the face of governments the
structure of government it's the
it's the same way i think about
my diet where previously it was
conscious brian looking at foods
in certain biochemical states am i
hungry am i irritated am i depressed and
then i choose
based upon those momentary windows do i
eat at night when i'm
fatigued and i have low willpower am i
going to pig out on something
and the current monetary system is based
upon
human conscious decision making and
politics and power and
this whole mess of things and what i
like about the building blocks of
cryptocurrency is it's methodical
it's structured it is uh accountable
it's transparent and so it introduces
this scaffolding
which i think again is the right
starting point for how we think
about building next generation
institutions for society and that's why
i think it's much broader much broader
than money
so i guess what you're saying is bitcoin
is the demotion of the conscious mind as
well
in the same way you were talking about
diet it's like giving less priority to
the
the ups and downs of any one particular
human mind in this case your own
and giving more power to the sort of
driven
yes yeah i i think that is
accurate that cryptocurrency
is a version of
what i would call my autonomous self
that i'm trying to build yeah
it is an introduction of an autonomous
system
of value exchange and value
and the process yeah of value creation
in society yes
as their similarities so i guess what
you're saying is bitcoin will somehow
help me not pig out at night
or the equivalent of
you